you got to talk about you on this Black
Adam World Tour already and of course
then we have a DJ moment
the sweetest thing we could ever do with
this little baby with the baby kissing
babies shaking hands I mean crazy
Michelle let me tell you something we
started the tour
um in Mexico the studio asked me months
ago you know there's we have all these
countries to choose from where do you
think where would you like to go I said
well without hearing your guys
researching what you guys want I think
we should start Mexico
America
I have a feeling the love and Mana is
going to be strong and I think Mexico
could set the tone for the rest of the
world and the tour so we get there we
have all these beautiful moments we have
a massive Fan event there's a lot of
Tears as we're I'm going around the red
carpet
interestingly enough
for the first time in my career
more men crying than
are you serious than women yeah there
were some women but more men so I'm out
on the stage and I look and I a guy
catches my eye and he's already weepy
not bawling but weepy and he's holding
this little doll and he's gesturing for
me to please please take this and he's
weeping and I went oh my god of course
sure yeah absolutely and then he goes
and he starts to crowd surf the infant
because it's a baby I thought it was a
dog
and I was and as it's coming like oh
that's a baby it's a real bad that's a
real baby so I said something to one of
my guys who run Logistics and security I
I said to him get the Navy if you win
what get the baby so he hands me the
baby what a beautiful moment though and
I gotta tell you just
I look then I look out at him and I'm
holding you can see me say oh my god
brother yeah he's crying now and it was
such a beautiful moment it was really
beautiful so whatever that whatever that
moment meant to him
whatever it was because I didn't get a
chance to speak to him then it just
meant something to me that is what you
do to people
to people the next question is you
running for president but you already
answered that you said no that's right
your family means more
a hundred percent now I have wrestled
with this decision I have been
asked from
very influential people on both sides of
the aisle uh for me to run I think
because according to them maybe I have a
little bit of ability to possibly bring
people together the most important role
for me right now is father and Daddy to
these little girls one six ones for and
I've worked so hard over the years I've
known you for a long time we've known
each other for a long time I've worked
so hard over the years to get to this
point right now where they're six four
we're enjoying life I got every drop off
every pickup
bedtime routine
the life that I want for them and the
stability that I want for them frankly
that I really never had when I was a
little boy and I had a complicated
relationship with my dad so
I'm a patriot I love our country and
everybody in it right now
it's those little girls I got you you
still have time but I didn't hear you I
want to know what Dwayne is like in
carpool in the carpool line are you
thinking you let people in are you like
no I've been here for 20 minutes I'm
easy okay as long as long as I get eyes
on my girl and I know you know where the
animal like oh no come on I'm on my
phone I'm getting business done I'm
listening to Def Leppard there you go
but a curse
out of Rage
reports are starting to trickle out that
this could be your biggest box office
Opening Ever how does that sit with you
um the moment I start to read that
headline I'm like nope I can't see it I
can't can't see it I get that way I get
a little jinxy and I get up but thank
you I will say that I feel great with
the movie we made and I think a lot of
people around the world are really gonna
like the movie I love that we took this
brand of DC that's been beloved over
these years for me too is a big fan and
now we could just stretch it out a
little bit and introduce these new
characters so whatever that means and
whatever that
equates to box office then Soviet a lot
of things I'd
dig this movie number one I'd really
like you as the anti-hero because we do
like you are beloved in a lot of ways
like that we don't always necessarily
like you mm-hmm in this movie I like
that too yeah I like that too yeah and I
feel like
um
our director John McLeod Sarah said it
best for me privately uh in one of the
oh it was the scene where all this who
plays Hawkman says we get into a
philosophical argument and then we get
into a big fight what you see and he
says listen you know Heroes don't kill
people right and I said well I do and
jalma came up and said there's so much
of you in Black Adam and so what do you
mean I don't kill people he goes I don't
mean that he said but just there is the
DJ we get yeah and he goes but then also
it's the DJ that and he excuse my
language but this is Jama speaking then
there's a DJ we don't absolutely right
abso freaking lutely but that's what I'm
saying that's what I like because I'm
like he's so nice but you know there's a
part of him that's like don't you the
part we saw on punked
the part we saw that is what I like to
see yeah I'm not sure
okay I want to ask you a real quick a
couple things the the mid credit scenes
the end credit yeah at the end credit
scenes um we got a little taste of
what's to come yes yes okay yes yes
absolutely so in Black Adam you'll see
some Easter eggs you'll get introduced a
lot of characters but what we wanted to
do and what was so incredibly important
to us to me to us us at seven bucks is
so I've been saying this thing
for almost a year now which is
there's a new era in the DC Universe and
it begins now and it begins with Black
Adam yes introduce new characters but
the new era Michelle to me means listen
to the fans
really listen to the fans not say you do
but we really listen to the fans and
that will inform and guide you on what
your next move is so what you saw at the
end of the movie that everyone is
early now losing their mind so yes
um
that's a reflection of listening to the
fans okay and that's also a reflection
of building to something okay so then
that means we're getting more than just
this movie from you how many more movies
I will say this the the goal is I would
we want to continue to build out the DC
Universe because there's so many places
to go with Black Adam with the JSA the
Justice League new characters that are
in the DC Bible that haven't been
introduced yet and it's really up to the
fans so when you talk about box office
and what this could potentially be uh
we'll see the box office will drive
everything but that is the overarching
goal
um
because I like to try and think five six
seven steps ahead I know you do yes I
know so yes that's the goal
[Music]